Hey Youtubers, it's Charlie huge news marvel
just confirmed the doing and inhumans TV show
in fall of 2017.
Like this time next year.
Some explain what the hell's going on with
is going to be awesome this is so crazy that
Marvel would do a list characters on TV in
this way you can kinda see what they're doing
is is like the in between option for doing
a character in the movies and do you character
on TV is like they started out with a big
blockbuster to our pilot that they drop in
IMAX theater and then they do the rest of
the series on TV like a normal TV show so
if you don't know what's going on inhumans
was originally going to be like a phase for
movie tail and phase 3 of them were gonna
work committed right after the first infinity
war movie.
But then supposedly there was a lot of infighting
behind the scenes Kevin fight he wasn't really
interested in doing inhumans.
He was the idea of Isaac Perlmutter the guy
who owns Marvel remember I did a big video
about how he almost Quach the Spider Man deal
with Sony and how he is generally thought
of is not the nicest person in the world is
like the toy guy at Marvel so supposedly he
really wanted the inhumans because he could
turn that into a big franchise it could be
like marbles version of X-Men, just because
of the way their powers work, but it seems
like what they're doing now is the just in
a try and turn it into Marvel's network game
of thrones because you have the iron throne.
In west roast now you have the throne of Atalanta
in the marvel universe.
So whatever happened behind the scenes they
made the decision to turn it into a TV show
it can be on ABC it will not be a spinoff
of agents of shield.
So it's not to rely on any of the canon that
they set up in the first couple of seasons.
So I think that's to their benefit there to
be able to do all of the comic book inhumans
royal family stub the series is supposed to
follow the origins of Black Bolt which means
they'll do the royal family go to Atalanta
all the stuff that you wanted them to do on
agents of shield in the movies they're going
to be doing that but it'll be on this inhumans
TV show they did say that the IMAX pilot is
gonna drop in September.
They didn't say exactly when, but they'll
be September and in the rest of the series
will premiere next fall.
Select literally next year we can have inhumans
TV show around this time so if you been disappointed
that agents of shield has thus far not done
a lot of movie stuff like this everything
is connected, but we haven't really seen any
of the avengers of any big stuff on the show
but we have ghostwriter's like the real exception
of that the season but it seems like next
year.
That's all going to change because the have
the inhumans TV show they can crossover with
agents of shield anytime they want to.
The thing about that, though the legacy like
a crossover haven't explained specifically
what time.
This is gonna take place during if it's gonna
be contemporary or if it's gonna be set in
the past.
So just to be determined on that like a couple
details they have not revealed yet limit what
you guys think of that royal family storyline
on TV I think it's gonna be a lot of fun.
It has a lot of potential but obviously we
need to see a trailer we need to see some
footage to see what is actually look like
it sounds like what they'll do is Buetow because
the gonna try and drop the pilot episode in
September in IMAX theaters.
The spent most of next year at the conventions
hyping it up the same way they hype up the
Netflix series if you want to read a good
inhumans, comic book story there a couple
out there but Rome of Kings was a lot of fun
Marvel Knights inhumans was really good and
then there was the storyline called inhumans
versus the Cree in 2000 and that was pretty
good to so be the way like you can pick up
any inhumans comic you want visitors a couple
suggestions of course when it gets here I'll
do videos for agents of shield is in its fourth
season I definitely think it's good to get
a season five pick up I think the ghostwriter
is driving a lot of the ratings.
So I think what they're doing is they're just
kind of planning for the future of Marvel
on ABC television with not getting ready to
cancel agents of shield or anything like that
but I think that they're just planning for
it to go off the air in the near future, so
they have something else waiting in the wings
is kind of the thing were the like slowly
trying to evolve the way they use these characters
on TV select agents of shield started out
real relatively real world there was a lot
of superhero stuff happening and they did
their own version of inhumans.
Now, they're doing Ghost Rider the just slowly
doing bigger and bigger stuff and then you
have the Netflix stuff is going on so I think
this in human show like there Marvel version
of game of thrones is like the answer to that
like you thought we were doing before was
cool.
This is going to be so much bigger.
So for those of you asking about CG and stuff
like that they been getting better and better
with the way they use e.g. in a really good
example of that is actually the flash TV show
the started to use more and more CG villains
which used to be super expensive but now it's
starting to get a little more affordable see
just do cooler stuff, so we have Apsley no
idea who the inhumans are is actually a quick
trailer here for inhumanity which is like
a special event in the comics the does a pretty
good job of explaining the broad strokes by
the zoo kind of feel like an X-Men style team.
They were created by Stanley and Jack Kirby's
way back in the day about two years after
they created the X-Men, so they debuted in
like a fantastic four title, so they were
like a fantastic four crossover initially
but here's the footage they have hidden in
our midst for centuries a strange race of
genetically enhanced beings known as the inhumans.
The result of an ancient experiment forced
on the planes of its spreading the catalytic
energies of the Terrigen Mists full of the
kingdom's rise to an army is across the globe,
countless thousands or review is always overall
and just as the pandemic continues to spread
the heroes of her's face the rise of the original
super human race with Miss the marvel universe,
so that event in the comics came at the end
of the infinity and it was meant to basically
like spread out this big new inhumans storyline
so that's probably not can happen on the TV
show the plug and with some other way they
use that is the fish oil on agents of shield
the TV show it was kind of their version of
the Terrigen bomb.
But as we learn more about the series I'll
do more videos will probably start dropping
more teasers early next year because if they're
going to get that pilot out by September that
means that start working on it real soon.
So will probably find out who's playing the
royal family characters relatively quickly
if you're bummed out.
This is going to be a movie.
Do not be sad.
Now they have up to 22 hours to develop these
characters instead of just two hours the problem
with movies is that he does have time for
character moment like it is a big action set
piece.
So in some cases like especially when you
have a big group of characters TV shows can
be better than the movies but be sure to subscribe
to get everything what's going to happen tonight
is I'll post my flash episode after that airs,
there's a whole much other stuff I'm trying
get to this week.
The other rumor that I'll leave you with is
that they're also gonna be dropping some Justice
League footage pretty soon.
They didn't say officially when but I'll talk
more about that when I post my flash video
while you guys wait for that to post you can
click here for a really cool Spider Man homecoming
interview video and you can click here to
learn all about young justice season three.
Thank you so much watching everybody high
five I'll see you guys tonight